[-All I want for Christmas is you.]
-Vous pensez entendre
le dernier titre de Mariah Carey ?
Il n'y aurait pas comme un écho ?
[-All I want for Christmas is you.]
[All I want for Christmas is you.]
-Eh oui. Cela fait bientôt 20 ans
que chaque année Mariah Carey..
..nous ressort son tube de Noël.
Seule la robe change.
Avec plus de 12 millions
d'exemplaires,
..elle est la plus grosse vendeuse
de disques des années 1990.
Grâce à ce titre, la diva s'est
offert une maison près de New York..
..d'une valeur
de 25 millions dollars.
[-I won't make a list
and send it...]
-Mariah Carey n'est pas la seule
à empocher au moment des fêtes.
Michael Bublé a vendu
5 millions d'albums,
..Christina Aguilera, 3 millions,
..et même le chouchou des ados,
Justin Bieber, s'y est mis.
[-It's the most beautiful
time of the year.]
[Lights fill the streets
spreading so much cheer.]
-C'est un exercice de style.
Là-bas, quelque soit son style,
rappeur, rockeur,
..ou fan de country,
l'artiste fait son album de Noël.
-C'est après guerre que la mode
est lancée aux Etats-Unis.
Frank Sinatra
avec "White Christmas",
..suivi par Elvis Presley.
Depuis, tout le monde s'y met,
..même les bad boys, ce qui donne
un mélange des genres insolites.
[-Everyday is like Christmas to me.]
[Everyday is like Christmas to me.]
-Comment ce business
profite-t-il aux stars ?
Les albums de Noël
se retrouveront-ils en masse..
..sous nos sapins cette année ?
-Je ne suis pas attirée..
..sur les reprises
de chansons de Noël spécialement.
-Cela ne me plaît pas
spécialement.
-Je me fais massacrer
si je mets les chants de Noël.
-Si les consommateurs font la fine
bouche, il y a un tube de Noël..
..made in France qui s'écoule
à 300 000 exemplaires chaque année.
[-Petit papa Noël...]
[-Quand tu descendras du ciel...]
-Le tube de Tino Rossi est
le single le plus vendu en France..
..depuis sa sortie en 1946.
Malgré ce succès,
..peu d'artistes francophones
ont tenté l'exercice.
Et il y a une raison à cela.
Aux Etats-Unis, Noël se prépare
dès septembre, alors qu'en France..
..cette fête ne dure
que quelques semaines.
C'est ce que nous explique Antoine,
..responsable marketing
d'une maison de disques.
-Quand vous avez 3 ou 4 mois
pour proposer un projet au public,
..vous pouvez proposer un album
avec des nouvelles chansons,
..car vous avez un laps
de temps pour le travailler,
..le commercialiser, le promouvoir,
qui est plus grand que 3 semaines.
-En France, on arrive quand même
à créer du business en 3 semaines.
Les ventes de disques augmentent
de 30 % sur cette période.
Le secret des artistes, sortir
des rééditions de leurs albums.
-C'est l'occasion..
..pour les artistes de proposer
quelque chose qui fasse cadeau.
Pas uniquement l'album
qu'on peut trouver toute l'année,
..mais vraiment un produit
qui a été pensé pour les fêtes.
-Les poids lourds de la chanson
française sont en tête de gondole,
..Mylène Farmer ou Johnny,
mais l'album qui cartonne..
..en ce moment, c'est celui-là.
[-ENVOLE-MOI,]
[..ENVOLE-MOI...]
-Génération Goldman,
..auxquels participent M. Pokora
et Tal, se vend rapidement.
130 000 albums écoulés
en 2 semaines,
..et pourtant
ce ne sont que des reprises.
-C'est peut-être..
..une stratégie marketing.
Mais je pense
que c'est bien pour Noël,
..pour les gens qui aiment
Jean-Jacques Goldman.
-A partir du moment..
..où l'album..
..est un cadeau potentiel,
c'est une période..
..qui est propice
pour sortir un album.
-Une stratégie commerciale
poussée à l'excès chez certains.
Regardez ces pochettes de
de Michael Bublé entre 2011 et 2012,
..la seule différence,
c'est la couleur du titre.
Cédric est chroniqueur musique.
Pour lui, Noël c'est l'occasion
de faire du neuf avec du vieux.
-Michael Bublé a compris
que c'était son créneau,
..et il ne lâchera pas.
-La star a quand même composé
3 inédits pour ce nouvel album..
..et a travaillé également
sa nouvelle chorégraphie.
Noël permet aussi de ressusciter
des stars disparues des écrans.
Cette année, l'album
le plus commercialisé..
..est sans doute "The Christmas"..
..de John Travolta
et Olivia Newton-John.
Pas sûr que ça marche
à tous les coups.
-C'est une fumisterie.
Ca reste très marketing.
On n'est pas sur
une dimension artistique,
..où les 2 nous ferons croire
qu'ils croient à la chrétienté.
-En France, sortir..
..un album de Noël est très risqué.
Mais les Tale of Voices
ont peut-être trouvé..
..la parade.
Ce groupe de 7 chanteurs..
..de gospel mélangent les reprises
de grands classiques français..
..et anglo-saxons.
[-Jingles bells, jingles bells,]
[..jingle all the way...]
-Ca nous permettait..
..de créer ce lien avec cette
culture qu'on affectionne beaucoup,
..et la culture française
avec les chants de Noël..
..qui sont bien encrés
dans la culture française.
-Le groupe s'est entouré
d'artistes reconnus,
..comme Julie Zenatti,
..sans doute pour toucher
un plus large public.
Et devinez quelle chanson
ils reprennent.
[-I just want you here tonight.]
-Reste à savoir si les Français
seront réceptifs à cette tradition..
..venue des Etats-Unis.
En tous cas, pour Noël,
les artistes ont bien pensé à vous.
-On souhaite un joyeux Noël...
-A 100 % Mag.
[-We wish you a merry Christmas...]
-Joyeux Noël, 100 % Mag !